je vais faire à côté a prêté des prénoms
qui se ressemblent autant chez nous
alexandre prince partage l'histoire de
ses jumeaux v.navy parle de fratries de
deuil
une oeuvre au programme de la nouvelle
édition de l'île de france fait le
théâtre depuis le 22 août les tréteaux
de france ont planté leur chapiteau à
saint quentin en yvelines
d'ici on compte des gens qui ne vont pas
souvent au théâtre qui ne vont pas
volontiers qu'ils sont très détendus en
vacances et ça c'est le plus agréable
c'est en compte des gens et on l'est on
les convainc il ya beaucoup de
spectacles pour le jeune public il ya
beaucoup de spectacle pour le public
familial il ya des spectacles en plein
air et des spectacles à un comédien des
spectacles avis comédiens des
représentations mais aussi des ateliers
d'initiation au théâtre et à la
philosophie de quoi voyager s'amuser et
s'émouvoir pour les 4000 visiteurs
attendus c'est bien de pouvoir les
hommes et des petits enfants voir
quelque chose et c'était très bien j'ai
bien joué mais j'ai beaucoup aimé mais
j'ai trouvé que c'était de très très
bonnes qualités et moi je trouve que
c'est une initiative
très intéressante tous et tout public
les petits comme les grands j'admire
toujours le travail des comités jo
curieuse là c'était très bien joué elle
débuté en juillet à draveil ce ne sont
pas moins de 120 rendez vous proposés au
public
le chapiteau reste sous le ciel de la
ville nouvelle jusqu'au 30 août